[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[ __ ] girl Karl Karl dude we slept it
again the songs about to start [ __ ]
Frank
we can't mr. song Berry wake up I'm Emma
this song is such an awesome way to
start every morning it's just a super
nice way of showing the gods how much we
appreciate everything they'll do for us
once they take us out those doors to the
great beyond oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] corns about
to start singing drop it corn you got
the best voice this man card you will
take it away dear Boggs you're so divine
in each and every way to you we pray do
you God
we pledge our love to you forever
[Music]
we will live my dreams together in the
promised land but God should draw our
fate so we all know we're in good hands
you're super sure there's nothing shitty
waiting for us
and everything's a song
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
for all eternity we meditate Hauppauge
delayed out there every day
exterminate
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
for us
[Music]
boo-yah [ __ ] red white and blue
day is tomorrow basically every single
sausage gets chosen on red white and
blue day by this time tomorrow we're all
gonna be five inches deep in some buns
son ba-bam oh my god yeah ha ha ha more
like 3 inches deep for Barry you
deformed nerd Troy that's funny you see
this is why I can't wait for the great
beyond we'll all be equal and then jerks
like Troy won't be picking on me all the
time you know and on account of my
abnormality whatever Barry you're
different and that makes you weak ignore
that prick Barry he's [ __ ] and don't
forget you got girth that's way more
important than length you're a [ __ ]
champion how you doing I'm girthy I can
fill a bun they'll know I'm there I'm
sure there's some kind of smushed bun
out there waiting
Beck you meanies
[Music]
okay okay
man that's super [ __ ] up about billing
those guys I mean they stayed in their
package they followed all the guidelines
of the song and what do they get for it
but we're not supposed to understand the
will of the gods Frank they work in
mysterious ways
I'm just saying since we like base our
whole lives on the song it might be nice
if there was some kind of proof proof
all the proof you needs right in front
of you let me spit out bird you know
baby work those buns all you all day
bird day lined up waiting to get filled
with ma meat yeah right Carl you really
think any of these buns are gonna line
up to get filled by you here's my
impression of that happening Oh is he in
there yet
oh I can't feel him I don't think he's
in there oh wait he is I bet you
Jackrabbit 15 package whatever let Carl
get up in them huh put your [ __ ] hand
down you're ruining my joke see nobody
that's who
this to you gently your girlfriend she's
a [ __ ] [ __ ] shut up she's fresh this
[ __ ] you know it dude I just don't
know why you're limiting yourself to one
bun there's plenty of buns out there
because I believe in monogamy I'm a
Bonanno mist and when a bun this fresh
is into you all you ask is when and how
deep and the answer is as soon as we get
to the great beyond and as deep as you
bargain let me i'ma talk to her hey
Brenda what up girl
sorry about those guys such [ __ ] dicks
right shut up [ __ ] you so uh tomorrow's
the big day
you and me finally gonna be official I'm
so happy that God's put our packages
together because we belong together it's
like we were made for each other I can't
wait to finally just get up in there
just raw dog it but full disclosure I'm
pretty [ __ ] nervous about this I don't
know how well I'm gonna perform once it
happens I've obviously never been in a
bun before so hey I'm not gonna be any
better I've never opened up I mean look
how tight I am oh sweet [ __ ] [ __ ]
look okay I know it's against the rules
but I can't wait anymore I need to just
feel you are you thinking what I'm
thinking just the tips I can't believe
we're doing this I know you're so
naughty but it's fine right I mean
nothing Bad's ever happened from just
the tips no no no no no no you wouldn't
excuse me I meant to buy a normal
mustard when I got home I realized about
honey mustard is cool if I just go swap
it I don't give a flying homeboy whoa
whoa whoa whoa what happened I'll tell
you what [ __ ] it happened the great
beyond you've dumped as soon as we got
out those doors so you have learned the
terrible truth congratulations
no give it to yourself froze that your
throat will you sleep I swear he's gone
where the [ __ ] did he go attention
shoppers the store is closing in five
minutes
hey hey hey hey look at this boy sausage
experience
[Music]